and this other stuff that you're doing
what is it is it Asian based or mixed
you know it's not now because I feel
like when I came in no it's just good
mechanism I just I have a tick yeah when
I hear somebody say something I have to
repeat it that's weird repeat it no the
way you said it was weird well it's good
I love you
thank you for having me we're the same
thank you for letting me hang out
outside with your uncle Paulie sandwich
we'll never do that again today when I
saw him out there he was a shivering
wait the sandwich you you picked it up
no it's just sitting in front of his
feet I was just chilling with it yeah
yeah yeah and I opened the door and
there he is I'm like where the [__] is
Jordan what's going on here yeah anyway
go ahead what what we're talking about
other [__] then you should oh yeah no I
got a new show at Showtime that we're in
development but it's looking pretty good
yeah I read that excited about that this
morning I read that this morning yeah
and that's more like about uh like the
Florida breaks music scene and how me
and my little homies were like just you
know doing and pills at the Advent of
ecstasy in Orlando when this like music
was created wow before Joe Biden passed
the Rave act and we were just wilding
out what is the Rave act the Rave Act
was because ecstasy was like scaring
Americans and parents so Joe Biden
passed this law I think in like 1999 to
like basically ban Raves because Raves
were like this playground where you
didn't need a liquor license or whatnot
like we were in 18 and under clubs
selling pills just going bananas yeah
and that's what the show is where am I
gonna get my glow sticks oh man
Spencer's Gifts are they oh yeah
oh yeah yeah I loved Braves because they
you should get in the map
back in the day in my time in the early
90s they would you go you would get a
rave map
and it's a map of like San Diego County
and then somebody would put a dot this
is where it's always in like
a forest or some place they're not
allowed to do it at and that was the
excitement finding it yeah yeah yeah it
was cool it was so cool cool yeah yeah
but then then but the dancing I Don't
Like
I love the music because the music is
I don't like it I was never a dancer
till I did that's actually the pilot
episode it's like I was never really a
dancer and then I did Exodus one time
and this girl like I couldn't blow up
because we were all listening to like
rap music like we were playing Master P
trying to blow up yeah I remember one
girl was just like yo this isn't how you
do it I was like what and she like put
on electronic music started dancing with
glow sticks and I was like oh my God I'm
about to nut my pants whoa that turned
you on yeah so you got laid there nah
I know you're married you love her I get
it right great but back I know but back
in the day dog all right listen man
during the Raves
no never no because that never happened
honestly on Molly like you could really
I feel like you really gotta get your
dick sucked for a minute before you like
can like do work like I gotta wait till
like the next morning really what do you
mean just because your [__] is not you
know all right the most vibrant always
you know I mean it's more mind sex
you're doing mind sex I feel like I love
it people may disagree or what that's
just how my [__] Works have sex yeah
they do a Vulcan mind meld oh yeah yeah
I was mind melding with Shorty
so but in the morning you would get some
maybe yeah but did you my point this is
my roundabout should be asking myself
way of asking you're gonna make did you
get a lot growing up body count huh
you know I did not get a lot growing up
me either but they were like
well I would say because I met my
well first girlfriend was like 14 or
something like that and then that's when
you lost your virginity nah but I had to
wait I waited till like 19 because also
my mom my mom was on my ass like my mom
would throw people at the house and
stuff like that and I just like I was an
abused kid I wasn't very comfortable
with my body like truth be told either
like I got the [__] kicked out of me too
by your dad yeah you know I really that
is a big part of this show like I I'm
it's funny I won't get like super deep
unless somebody asked me to but the show
is a lot of it is about this [__] that I
felt growing up and how ecstasy actually
helped me right is because I felt like
my body was trash like complete trash
which is kind of interesting because
they are doing like Molly assisted
therapy now yeah and like I without
anyone saying it I was just like this
[__] really helped me because I thought
my body was trash this one night this
girl was like dancing and all this and I
was like this is amazing I was dancing
with her and then I just danced for five
hours and it was the first time I ever
felt like my body was not trash wow and
I was I got this ill Confidence from
this one night doing ecstasy